I'm gonna get one of those vultures one
day I'm gonna get one I don't know why
it's so important to you
I just feel like you would make me feel
better oh no it's a little lion that is
not alive well then go check it out what
it's not a lion it's a furry bird it
looks like a lion let me get a closer
look excuse me all right let me see what
we're dealing with here it's a lion it
gets bigger can we keep them can we
please keep him oh I promise I'll walk
in every day if he makes a little mess
I'll clean it up you'll be his little
mess he's gonna eat you and then use my
body as a toothpick but one day when
he's big and strong he'll be on our side
I've got it what if he's on our side
hear me out having a ferocious lion
around might not be such a bad idea
Timon and Pumbaa I cannot name a more
iconic duo
like you guys stole the show for me
you're the most iconic duo and there was
so much of you in each of these
characters that for me I know that this
movie is a classic but I left thinking
you know when it came to the Lions how
far did you guys want to take it and did
you ever go too far that they had to
like take stuff out I'm sure that we did
there yeah I was in hours and hours of
unusable material yeah Johnson you could
probably make a whole separate movie
based on all the riffing we did that was
not used in the actual version that made
it into the final cut but yeah those
were some long recording sessions and as
they go on you get really loopy and
loose and start saying things that are
wildly inappropriate to the Lion King
but which make you laugh in the moment
but yeah we had fun we really did you
know once we got over the hurdle of oh
god we're remaking the Lion King we had
a blast yeah and you guys got to record
together your chemistry was just I mean
I felt the love that night yeah yeah I
think you can tell yeah they feel like
what's weird is this technical a movie
it is there's also something about it
that's like wildly naturalistic I think
especially with the way our characters
interact with one another and it like is
a good like counterbalance I think oh we
blew it away boy Oh a moment
what was it truly like being in the same
room as Donald Glover and singing huge
disappoint I didn't expect to be singing
the song with Donald the Billy in a rube
that's to say it's just so
unconventional like you wouldn't
normally ever the dialog is one thing
but for all of us actually likes it
because we like the version of Hakuna
Matata that's in the movie like was all
of us in a room this this far away from
each other just like singing at each
other's faces yeah I know and yeah like
as someone who is not the greatest
singer like it's like having to play
basketball with like LeBron James or
there's like I felt like a fool I said
you're actually part of a very special
Club because according to the internet
yes Pumbaa is one of the first Disney
animated characters to ever fart in a
film yes so how does it feel to be a
part of something so special like that
well it was I guess I mean I'd said yes
to fill the roles of the shoes of that
yeah yeah it's an honor it's a real
honor yeah yeah
and I say fart in this version of the
movies Wow that's right that's right
yeah yeah don't see that Snow White
exactly the first character to say fart
in a Disney yeah which would be
fantastic yes there's an Oscar for that
exactly life's not fair
visit my little friend while some are
born to feast others spend their lives
in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps congratulations what
an epic project to be a part of and what
I loved most about this film leaving was
that the relationship and storyline
between your two characters are expanded
a little bit so without giving too much
away you know can we talk about some of
the new things audiences will learn
going into this film about the
relationship between your two characters
I think we know more in reality about
relationships I think we know more about
ourselves as a as a human culture about
our psychology and so I think this
version does not disregard that I'll
just say that it is the storyline and
all but it's it's like when you know
when the grown-ups are in the room
there's certain things they're talking
over your head but I think they kind of
let you in on what mom dad and the
postman yeah I think it's just that they
have a complex relationship you know
that they that all of these dynamics are
complex and we and then in this version
that's just explored a little more you
know I mean all of that is the Vino it's
all laid out there and there in the
original but it's so but it's just kind
of slightly more pushed you know yeah as
a lover of the animated I left
understanding the animated so much more
so I appreciated that so much but Sarabi
and Skaar are so iconic what did you
both want to personally bring to these
characters I wanted to fill her out I
wanted you to be able to smell the
lionesses one of the things that happens
was when you're in the wild and animals
are in their habitat the first thing
that hits you before you see them is
their smell you know and it brings up
something in you because we're animals
it puts you on alert and you know that
you're in somebody's territory and then
the second thing is the movement
especially a felines movement is very
specific so trying to incorporate that
and the weight of being one of them
two lionesses to try to find that in
your voice yeah I think it's just that
you know for me that sort of
psychological complexity which I just
think is so it's you know it's all laid
out there but it's just just uncovering
that as much as possible and really sort
of understanding that in terms of
scanner is was really great
well you guys nailed it and you have you
know incredible careers but you both
have done voice work in the past as well
so where does the Lion King rank you
know in everything you both have done
and does it compare to anything you've
done before for me it ranks really high
you know as an experience of taking and
of looking at something that is iconic
and retelling it in this way and then
working with John and all of this
technology and how that is advanced in a
period of time it's it's a really
remarkable thing to sort of be a part of
and to to to engage with I'm very
excited about about audiences experience
enough with a little practice you'll
never be called a cub again watch this
you'll get it Simba just takes time I'll
check on you later dad will be so proud
Wally it's a gift he'll never forget
Hakuna Matata it's a wonderful phrase
what does it mean to you guys I'll tell
you what it means to me right now I have
been in my sort of you know right before
rim and then right out of REM sleep I'm
going oh god then it makes me kind of
smiled normally if I had a pop song luck
I'd be pissing like Jesus I get up in
the morning I just go you're the man
that part Robert Downey jr. in the Iron
Man's yes yes I was part of that you put
Will Ferrell in DLC
yes you are the casting master this
movie is no exception can you let me
into your casting process a little bit I
think you're hitting on something that's
really important is that certainly the
types of movies I do is only as good or
as bad as my cast and so that's one area
that I will not compromise and and so
often when you're making a movie you
come up with lists and you sort of
negotiate back and forth with the people
paying for it but for me I
no I I have a really good eye and
understand I could really see the talent
and other people and I could create an
environment to let them do their thing
that's that's really what I take the
most pride in and then once you have
that it's it becomes much easier to
build the world around them so Robert as
iron man or you know Will Ferrell was
already attached to elf at the time but
I saw it with him and in that costume
and his wonderful performance so you
know and and then with Lion King you
know we couldn't change too much of the
story because there's people of your
generation who grew up with that movie
and they know it beat for beat and so we
wanted to stay true to the story and you
had to keep the music right because that
musics the best music I could think of
in in movies
Hakuna Matata yes sounding great and so
the cast is what you really rely on and
the technology to reinvent it and make
it fresh and new and so hearing all
these actors interpretations of these
roles and these songs is what I think
makes it something that I I really am
very proud of well you should be because
you nailed it and you now have two
Disney animated remakes under your belt
yes jungle book and Lion King is there a
classic Disney animated movie that
hasn't been remade yet that you would
love to direct well that's a tough
question this particular film of Lion
King I felt confident that I could do
something cool with because of my
experience on Jungle Book and I think
each animated film is like a puzzle and
part of it is you have to determine
whether it is something you should
remake and if you do what techniques do
you use and so you look at Beauty and
the Beast is a much different technique
than Milan or you know or what we did
here is different than Cinderella and
it's what combination of elements makes
it memorable and so I think each
filmmaker has to you know find a
different road for them this one I knew
the music was important and I thought
that the naturalism presenting it as
though it was like almost a nature
documentary would differentiate it from
both the stage show and the and the
animation class and in Jungle Book you
actually voiced a hog so I did
will we be hearing your voice in this no
I'm not in this one I've had you know
who sort of did that it was um you know
I sort of did a lot of little things in
that and we had chance the rapper who's
a big fan of the original and he's
friends with Donald Glover and I would
show him footage a lot because he was so
he was such a great audience and
understood the old movie so well and as
he was around I'd be like you want to do
you know a voice or cup and he was he
was up to have fun and play and so he's
like the bush baby but he's also I think
half the animals in the forest so as you
see all the all the laughs of all those
little one-liners half of them are
chance that's all chance they're at a
lot of us him there's Amy Sedaris and
there also there's Josh McCreary which
is JD's brother who
please young Simba so it's a it's a
whole little family affair in their
friends and family and and it's really
at but they're great I mean it's some of
the funniest stuff in the movie
you